n'hésitez pas laisser porter vos deux
voix assez loin pour que dernier conseil
avant le grand saut toute la classe a
joué le jeu oser monter sur scène pour
dire sa vision de l'agriculture en 2030
avec une grange en guise de théâtre
l'action se passe au salon de
l'agriculture là où les paysans de toute
la france échangent sur leurs pratiques
des 600 hectares de cultures seraient
possibles avec 4 points et en plus on va
vers la robe en tissage on n'aura jamais
le temps nous au pardon de boire était
montée sous franchement vous avez tous
les visiteurs si ça continue mais vous
ne vous êtes jamais dit que vous
pratiquez des complémentaires quatre
courtes scènes avec à chaque fois du
débat de la friction mais à la fin il ya
toujours un terrain d'entente implantée
au coeur du pays du comté ces étudiants
du lycée agricole de levier ont déjà
intégré les valeurs de cette filière si
particulière
l'esprit coopératif la solidarité
surtout on peut dire ça il se re partage
de la valeur ajoutée à la fin et c'est
un maillon enfin tout le monde
s'entraide on va dire c'est ça qui fait
la force de la op c'est du comté aop 18
mois d'affinage les enjeux en
agriculture bourg sont nombreux de plus
en plus important et ça mobilise à
nouveau mobilisés vers nos jeunes qui
sont en formation de nouvelles
compétences entre autres savoir
clairement s'exprimer parler
correctement de son métier
savoir exprimer j'allais dire les freins
les moteurs aux changements
[Musique]
c'est important pour eux évidemment de
ceux projetés et s'imaginer différents
scénarii qu'est ce que va être
l'agriculture dans 8 10 ans mais même
vin en difficulté pour s'installer
cohabitation entre les filières ce sont
les étudiants qui ont écrit les textes
aujourd'hui dans cette classe il ya
autant de filles que de garçons le thème
des femmes dans l'agriculture s'est vite
imposé vous les femmes vous et des
petites natures et non règles aux sautes
d'humeur faut vous suivre un que vous
pleurez après vous râlez les vaches ne
vont pas vous suivre ici c'est dur et
travail des dialogues inspirés de leur
vécu ces futurs agriculteurs sont aussi
lucide qu'optimiste